this summer we're getting honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this is honest trailers blockbuster
summer from Disney and the guy who shot
diehard comes three action scenes
stacked on top of each other under a
trenchcoat pretending to be a movie
[Music]
speed some were in Los Angeles there's a
bomb on a bus and if it slows down it
will explode if it drops below 50
exactly it'll blow yes it's not that
complicated
we know you tell that wild cat behind
the wheel not to slow down though it's
called speed we get it okay moving on we
meet la cop Jack Traven
he's young dumb and full of gum Jack and
his partner may be the Dumber halves of
their comedy duo's but now they explode
with rage whenever they're outsmarted
[Music]
or just explode
they're up against Howard Payne one of
the great phone-based villains of the
90s I got your attention now you've
probably got no [ __ ] idea what I'm
talking about this unpleasant don't let
it happen again
tennis Harbor thrills as the Joker
without the make up in such a convincing
madman performance
you won't even question why he holds the
phone all weird sure a bomb injured his
left hand but it made his right ear go
deaf next you're gonna tell me cars
don't fly
[Music]
climb aboard a bus full of people who
either just found out they're going to
die or that's just how everyone looks
when they're on a bus then Rev your
engines as Sandra Bullock goes from that
girl and demolition man to America's
Sweetheart
all thanks to Halle Berry for passing on
the role and Ellen DeGeneres - that
would have been weird do you ever
thanked me for your career sandy will
shine as a woman who does her best to
keep the bus above 50 while keeping the
chemistry above zero with a human
equivalent of a Zen rock garden I don't
care what the speedometer says there's
no way the bus is doing more than 30
tops and I'm so much smarter than this
movie which isn't really saying much I'm
gonna go home have some sex
forget the romance this film is all
about the action and you know things are
gonna go fast but when things get in the
way of going fast the only solution is
for those things to go faster they could
jump the track is any of this possible
no but also shut up this is speed not
gravity
[Music]
okay that's pretty dumb - so right along
for a simple action blockbuster that
just plain works thanks to its likeable
stars snappy dialogue from an uncredited
Joss Whedon we're at the airport yeah so
I already seen the airport and a
building release of tension that's so
masterful even the victims on the bus
are caught up in the foot
stop cheering you're all gonna die and
even if you don't you're still on a bus
that's better starring John quick Dennis
the Menace bird bus sometimes I doubt
your commitment to Sparkle motion buses
moved pretty fast if you stop and look
around once in a while you'll explode
90s gizmos 90s dancing is this really
how anyone has danced like ever and
whatever Joe lets us play the Dumb and
Dumber diarrhea quit mr. woes Wild Ride
Interactive TV jack wave of the future
it's called YouTube mr. hopper and
you're on it to fit even more game of
thrones into your eyeballs click the box
to watch our after-show watching Thrones
or you need to get caught up before the
game concludes check out our Kremen of
the complete series I feel the need the
need for speed oh I have inevitable I am
in elbows but they rule